I'm stuck I know you want me to save
myself
so I brothers will never forget you I
suggest you promise that come back
you ready I mean Akaka nunchaku Oh I'll
be waiting
dad
all right what was that last thing you
said what that last one I didn't catch
it well is anything what do you mean I
didn't what I said I'll be waiting and
then I stopped talking dad the Lloyd
that's right your son and it's join no
ll oh why do I named you you ruined my
life that's not true I haven't even been
a part of your life how could I ruin it
wasn't even there baby now we got bad
I'm taking this Alamo to pop the speaker
ninja pork are you ready to risk your
life for Ninjago yes I am
maybe look I know you want me to save
myself so I'll go now I promise I'll
never forget you didn't you promise that
come back
hello Lloyd Garmadon your son it's okay
Lloyd nobody's parents are perfect I
mean my mom is weird and collect
seashells your dad level cities and
attacks innocent people so they've all
got that quarks you know
you